l'hécatombe sur les routes c'est
l'actualité quotidienne hélas comme le
sont les élections en israël ou en
algérie nous en parlons chaque jour mais
en ce moment même il y à un pays dont on
parle très peu
et pourtant ce qui s'y passe est peut
être comparable drame du biafra au
soudan en effet il y à la guerre civile
il ya eu la famine
il ya les inondations résultat des
centaines de milliers de personnes sont
en train de mourir
voici le terrible reportage que vient de
nous faire parvenir notre envoyé spécial
chaque dos et elle salue le ciel par qui
l'aide alimentaire est enfin arrivé
c'est la joie à dieye petite localité du
sud soudan
coupés du monde depuis six mois et où
plus de 3000 personnes viennent de
mourir sans aucune assistance
c'est la joie abyei
le ciel a envoyé cet avion qui a pour
nom cicr fait d'un pont aérien financé
par la croix-rouge et le croissant-rouge
soudanais
il était temps
mais pour certains d'entre eux il est
trop tard la malnutrition trop avancé le
mâle irréversible cela fait six mois que
l'avion aurait dû arriver aujourd'hui
seraient manuel le sourire des
bidonvilles de khartoum est aussi
descendu à abyei
elle s'est battue avec les organisations
internationales contre toutes sortes de
difficultés d'ordre bureaucratique
logistique et surtout politiques qui ont
empêché les secours d'arriver
bernard kouchner est là lui aussi
secrétaire d'état à l'action humanitaire
il est venu étudier la façon dont la
france pourrait elle aussi contribuer à
soulager la famine au sud soudan
la situation est complexe la région en
proie à la guérilla et difficile d'accès
une solution est envisagée via la
république de centrafrique le président
du conseil du sud-soudan monsieur vida a
demandé hier au gouvernement français
d'intervenir auprès des rebelles afin
qu'ils acceptent un cessez le feu de 90
jours pour permettre l'acheminement des
secours
car pour l'instant si c'est la joie
abyei il est impossible de mesurer
l'étendue du désastre
dans le reste de la région une
évaluation faite par le comité
gouvernemental des secours fait état de
225 mille personnes touchées par la
famine au sud soudan essentiellement des
chrétiens animistes